un train a découvert comme ça enfin moi
c'est la première fois que j'en prends
un donc là c'est trop ça carrément
montagne à droite montagne à gauche et
ciel ouvert enfin c'est incroyable et je
pèse les mots
[Musique]
chez Colliou aujourd'hui c'est pour
revenir visiter la région on va faire un
trip de 2 jours on va partir tout à
l'heure vers Villefranche de Conflans
donc on va diriger tout doucement vers
les Pyrénées pour rejoindre la carence
avec le petit train jaune comment j'ai
organisé mon voyage pour les
déplacements j'ai utilisé bah du coup
l'application SNCF Connect que j'utilise
quand même assez régulièrement pour pour
du couvre les horaires de train qui a
pas besoin de s'embêter avec chercher
les correspondances etc tout est fait
automatiquement donc on peut vraiment
les partout avec avec l'appli donc ça
c'est cool on va aller voir le village
toutes les maisons colorées de Collioure
on se protège c'est important 50 enfants
sont Steve je suis breton moi le soleil
et je suis pas encore devant moi je vois
le château royal de Collioure le bord de
plage de Collioure les petits
restaurants je te propose de te montrer
mon coin préféré regarde
là tu as une petite porte les volets
bleus la mer qui est bleu bleu bleu
c'est trop beau et puis ta vie il y a
personne en plus
[Musique]
on est à Villefranche de Conflans dans
les Pyrénées-Orientales dans une dans
une ville un peu fortifiée quand même
Vauban je crois et avec du coup tous les
remparts autour un peu encaissés au
milieu de la montagne tout à l'heure on
est en train de se baigner dans la
Méditerranée et se dire qu'on a accès à
tout ça du coup juste en français c'est
quand même absolument fou on vous donne
rendez-vous à demain on va prendre du
coup le Train Jaune donc un train un peu
mythique quand même de la région à hâte
de voir ça quoi je privilégie le train
dans mes voyages j'habite à Montpellier
maintenant et tu peux passer bah du coup
de la Méditerranée comme on l'a fait
aujourd'hui aux montagnes les Pyrénées
et en fait en quelques trains 1 2 voire
trois trains tu as accès des paysages
complètement différents au niveau de la
région il y a pas mal de d'offres pour
les jeunes qui avec pas mal de trains en
euros c'est que tu peux aller quasiment
où tu veux et pour 1 euro c'est
clairement c'est clairement pas cher et
tu as pu cette barrière de bah déjà de
la distance du transport après sur le
côté purement écologique c'est vrai que
déjà le fait de pas mettre des voitures
en plus sur la route de d'avoir un moyen
de transport qui ait des carboné c'est
quand même hyper important c'est la
première expérience du Train Jaune on le
voit partout en photo et vidéo et trop
content de le prendre aujourd'hui
[Musique]
dans la région de la région Occitanie
avait quand même une assez grande
diversité de paysages passés des
Pyrénées de la montagne la Méditerranée
dans les gorges de la carrossa trop trop
beau exactement c'est à quoi je
m'attendais en mieux mais encore les
prochains endroits de la région que
j'aimerais visiter c'est les Cévennes
cet été je vais clairement profiter de
la plage et puis en septembre octobre
j'ai trop chaud pour aller randonnée
dans les Cévennes